we're just going to move now to our top
story the announcement of the formation
of a new government in tunisia the
president kai saeed is speaking now
let's take a listen indeed
and its institutions
and the tunisian people
today
and that comes after
several previous warnings
who entertained the idea
of attacking
the
state and its institutions
or the people and the property
it took me a long time to announce a new
cabinet
as if the problem was in forming a new
cabinet
tunisia didn't have a government until
1969
and there was a council for these senior
officials
what have they got to do with
forming a cabinet to choosing members of
the cabinet
we are not controlled by anyone
but because the constitution stipulates
that there should be a government we
have announced a new government
and we've done that faster than they had
expected
after
giving the mandate to her excellency the
head of the government
the first of its kind in tunisia and
other arab countries
and it's a great honor to the tunisian
woman
tunisian woman is not a cosmetic to make
the institutions look
more
to embellish institutions
i did not
speed up or neither was i late
because the issue is not related to a
cabinet
but to the entire to the entire system
and a system that still exists
that has been there for tens of years
each
single element consolidates the other
so that the system
would continue to operate to serve
various lobbies
i'm not walking through
a national liberation
should know who are their faithful
friends
25th of
july
was an historic moment
in the full sense of the word
on that evening
to return them
to their
[Music]
i took that decision alone
in front of god
what am i gonna tell god on the day of
judgment
when i see the tunisians
dying every day
thanks to the efficiency and the
competence
within three weeks
after
people were dying every day tens of them
thanks to tunisian people
men and women and its forces
its military forces and security forces
and thanks to its doctors
and the civilian sector and the youth
the number of those
who had contracted the infection
and those who died thanks to all those
people who contributed to that effort
civilian officials
they want the vaccine and they can
choose which type of vaccine
and even abroad they took to the streets
because they felt there was hope again
after the nightmares
had weighed heavily
on the minds of the people
after the 25th of july
i noticed with a great deal of pain
how people changed positions
people were trying to seize various
opportunities
from those who were
waiting for an opportunity
but
there was those who
cheered them on
and after that
they became
an opposition
to demand
to return to what
there was between 25th of july
to a formal nominal legitimacy
that was tailored to suit their purposes
like a pair of shoes
and they paid the money
and they continue to change their
positions
and that is how they portray the
situation as if it was a coup
how could it be called a coup
based on a constitutional
on the constitution after i had
consulted the head of the government
and the head of the parliament
in line with the constitution
these were exceptional measures
stipulated by the constitution
in case there is an imminent danger but
the danger
continues
should we
leave the country and the people
[Music]
but light has started to emerge
on the evening of the 25th of july
light has started to
shine on the land
today i have brought you
some pictures for those who wish to
forget
and i want the photographers
to turn their cameras
this is the picture of the parliament
have they forgotten that
another picture
for the parliament
can't they see that
another picture
another picture for the parliament
have they forgotten that
and three bills
well
yesterday they wanted to go back to this
that to this situation that prevailed
inside the parliament
swear words
and this is what happened to one of the
women members of parliament after it was
rescued by the police
they have
their own agendas
under these dark circumstances
given this tragic picture
day by day
and those who were supposed to represent
the people
and i'm not talking about everyone but
those who stood firm
but those
despite that
for achieving the goals
of the revolution and fighting
corruption
that was the tunisian president kai
saeed announcing the new government and
revealing a new cabinet the swearing-in
ceremony has been completed a short time
ago in the capital he says that they've
done it in quote a faster than expected
time he also spoke about the selection
of women there are 24 members of his new
government including seven women saeed
abruptly dismissed the prime minister
and assumed all executive powers in
uh july 25th and he said he was seeking
to save the country from a deteriorating
economic political and health crisis for
more on this story now let's bring in
our guest simon speakman who's in tunis
he's an independent journalist simon
what do you make of this swearing
swearing-in ceremony and his picks today
well like so much it's been sprung on us
with very little warning i've been going
through the list of ministers now and it
seems a broadly competent government
um a lot of the heavy lifting is going
to have to be done by the finance
minister uh sahim budhiri now
quickly looking at her background she
seems to be an economist she's worked
for the ministry of finance and she has
a lot of work ahead of her
um i think based on past conversations
with various diplomats they were really
looking
for um at this position above all else
um the appointment to the prime minister
was very important it was a big step
forward but it wasn't the vital you know
part of the puzzle that they were
looking for that was the finance
minister my understanding is that with a
good finance minister teamed with the
head of the central bank who they have
faith in that's a guy called miran
abbasi
that's going to be the team that they
will deal with to
maybe get the economy moving talk to the
imf negotiate the international loans
and perhaps move forward with the
economy that tunisia desperately needs
um in the meantime as we saw yesterday
there is
perhaps something of a groundswell
against the president though that
remains in the minority were certainly
thousands of protesters within the city
center yesterday protesting against his
july the 25th
power grab
simon thank you for that
the president said in that speech i'm
not sure if you heard but he said that
it was they've achieved somewhat of a
miracle what do you think he meant by
that
um that he has actually managed to
progress to this stage um i remember i
went to the parliament on july the 26th
that's the day after
um president saying announces
extraordinary measures
and i was sorry about the noise and i
was told by
um
army officers there that they were
expecting a chief of government that day
you know we're now in october and we've
finally got a government which might
mean that this country can start moving
again i mean it sorely means to
what do you make of the timing i mean
you did mention it just briefly then but
you know this has been happening since
july what's the sort of mood on the
ground there from tunisian people and
also from
you know the likes of fellow
journalists and politicians
well
frustration
um
and
impatience i think would be the key
things i mean we
journalists taught we talked to
politicians we talked to you know
yesterday at the
manifestation
people are in the crowd
and nobody
has really understands what's going on
in july the 25th we thought we were
seeing part of this very sort of
three-dimensional chess intricate game
and now october that's not the case he
seems to be moving very slowly until now
he's not mentioned the economy
and that is one of the vital issues i
mean this was is his greatest risk and
it's also possibly a great opportunity
um
i think that the protest yesterday
was a factor but i would not say a
deciding factor these names these people
had all been interviewed long in the
past and he had assembled them it seems
i mean that's very early days a fairly
reasonable team i would need to do some
more studying
well we look forward to more updates
thank you for your insights there simon
speakman who's live for us in tunis an
independent journalist